hello everybody
and welcome you all so this is your host
amarjeet and i'll be taking you once
again to the similar tour of angular
and you know it very well previously we
have developed a lot of projects in
angular
and this time also we will like to make
sure that we offer you some very
consistent project this time
where it will help you to connect all
the dots of whatever you have learned in
an angular
so this particular session will be more
specific towards the project
so stay tuned with me because this time
we'll be offering you a lot of
beautiful gui which can combine together
to understand how angular can be best
suitable
for the front-end application and to
make it happen
you understand like in this particular
project we'll be having
a basic angular setup ready so you know
it very well
to develop an angular application we
have used a similar technique called
uh downloading the angular cli version
and we have used ngnu
and the name of the project is project
and this
particular project does nothing has only
one single
component name called app as you can see
it right now here
under the src you have a got app folder
app component dot
html and here you see appcomponen.ts
so that is one of the very very basic
component angular can hold in
so this edge table contains a very
simple message called welcome
and component.ts contains nothing
special it is just holding one title and
app.module.ts if you see it contains
nothing special
whatever it comes as a predefined
preloaded it contains only those
particular type of modules
and in my app.module.ts sorry
yeah if you talk about call package.json
inside my package.json we have some
additional dependency added
which i will tell you like what
dependencies a part of angular which
comes as a preloaded
are by default available now you can see
here
animation compiler core forms localized
these are all by default are there
a part of that we have also taken this
bootstrap
as an additional dependency so we talk
about called ng bootstrap
okay which is the additional dependency
we have taken bootstrap
jquery copper.js rxjs which anyways
comes by default
and here these dependencies will be
playing
additional role during your development
time
okay rest everything gonna be remain
same as it is
but yes these additional dependencies
like in jquery poker
and your save tslip and you talk about
like in bootstrap
okay jquery these libraries are
additional to those
the one which comes as a by default okay
so once you have those additional
dependencies added into your project do
not forget that in your angular.json
you need to have additional
declarations to be get added okay as you
can see now under the scripts part
okay under the styles part you see the
under the styles we have kept
our bootstrap.min.css
and under the scripts we have kept all
those necessary
dependencies with regards to our js
called demo
chart pie chart by demo you talk about
bootstrap you talk about jquery
so these are the additional dependencies
we have kept under the scripts part
which is here under your wrangler.json
okay and under the styles we have about
bootstrap
through which we can directly include
these bootstrap related stuff
directly into my project so that would
be
the first thing which will start with
okay
so if i want to start my application i
will certainly say
npm space start let me say npm space
start
if it is launching my application
okay please use sudo
now it is launching and under the port
number 4200
my application will be starting up now
it is saying
port maybe this application is ready
somewhere
so let me check if it is available
okay so application is already running
so inside my 4200 if i try to run
i can see this by default message
welcome appears
so that's the only thing with regards to
your project so nothing fancy it is just
a basic stuff
your application have some basic set of
dependencies added
and along with this uh you have some
new dependencies and you just you say
npm space start and
under the localhost 4200 your project
will get ready
okay so in my previous example you
remember like we have created
and done with our basic setup and now
it's time for us to go back
and create some new component into my
project
now what are the first component i'm
looking forward for that is called
navbar
for creating a navigation so inside this
first of all
i want to open a new one
okay so i want to say ng space g space c
space nav bar
so let the new component get ready okay
so we have got never component ready
with me
so this is what my navbar is and inside
this navbar
i want to add some additional
dependencies inside my html
okay so here i may have lot of tags
associated with me
but here i want to start with my body
tag
okay so this is what i want to start
with my body tag
okay and here onwards we want to start
all my development
so within my body tag i will be writing
a lot of other tags too
but first of all let me try to have some
additional dependencies to get added
here
so i want to add the div and
here i would like to have some
additional dependencies to be get added
as you can see right now
it is for jquery it is for your
bootstrap it is a
scripts okay this is for
charts this is for chart areas data
tables
so these dependencies are very much
required in order to start
your basic development
okay and i want to continue developing
this example
by adding some new logic one by one
okay now what logic i want to add it now
so
i will be using bootstrap as a basic
code
okay so first of all i want to use the
body
with some body class
equal to i want to give this name called
sb hyphen
nav hyphen fixed that is actually the
bootstrap class
which we're associating with here and
here after that
we'll be starting with my div tag so
after body
here see this is the sb hyphen nav
hyphen fix which we have used now i'll
be using some
nav tag now and inside my nav tag
i want to say class equal to
sb hyphen top nav
space nav navbar space
nava hyphen expand
okay space nav bar hyphen
we want to use the dark theme so i'll be
using naval hyphen dark
and space bg hyphen
dark so this is the first thing we are
using it now
now inside my nav okay we want to use
few more important details like i am
saying like anchor
okay so with this anchor i want to say
a before hdf we want to say class
equal to navbar
never hyphen brand
okay space nav bar
or else we can say hrx we can use this
just add this single quotation and just
say href
hr is equal to index dot
html to go back and after this will be
also using this img tag also
so we just use this img src
will be using some logo okay which will
be there under the assets
okay under the assets i'll be having
logo
dot png
okay and we would like to also uh say
some controlling this some width and
height so we just use width
equal to what 80 percent
okay and we want to use height
equal to 120 percent
so where's 80 percent height 120 percent
alt is maybe something optional you want
to give it
i just want to leave it now we do not
want to give art as an alternative
and if you also want to give style
so i say style equal to
now i say padding hyphen top
colon here i say 10
pixels
okay that's it so that's where exactly
the
main logic is let me try to bring this
back
okay and here the anchor tag is closed
after this i'll be using my
button tag now
with this button we want to add some
class
class equal to btn
space btn hyphen
link followed by btn
hyphen sm because i want to have a small
size button
and i want to say order iphone one
space order
iphone lg hyphen
0 okay followed by id
equal to
sidebar toggle
what i'm saying sidebar toggle and after
that
some more new properties like an h ref i
do not want to go anywhere so i'm just
saying
hrf equal to what hash in the single
quotes
like this okay
and that's it so within this button
i would like to offer some i class
so here i say i class i
class equal to
[Music]
okay fas fa hyphen bars
okay this is a special class available
and
that's it which is there
now here the i class is getting close
and here the button is getting close now
okay so this is the first part of my
code now
okay now we talk about call navigation
on nav bar search so here
i'm starting with my
never search
okay so inside my navbar search we would
like to offer
some more new number of fields so called
form
okay so i start with my form now
with this form i may not say
action for a time being so i'm just
removing this
action from this instead
we are saying form class equal to
d d hyphen
none space md
hyphen
inline okay hyphen block
hyphen block okay
so md hyphen inline hyphen block after
that you have to suggest form
hyphen and here you see inline because i
want to go ahead with the inline form
and also ml hyphen auto
space mr hyphen 0
space mr iphone md
hyphen 3 my iphone
2 space my iphone
md hyphen 0
so this is what all about our form but
within this form is not a closed it is
just a first portion of the form plus
along with this will be also offering
the dip class so we just use
them here i say
class equal to input hyphen
group input hyphen
group and now
inside this input item group i want to
use input class
input type equal to text and here
i say class input
class equal to
form hyphen
control for hyphen control
we would like to add few more classes
here first it is
form control type equal to what type it
is a type text and now we say
placeholder equal to
search
for okay
this is the property for me where i want
to use it
and a part of that
search for we're giving it so since it
is giving so we do not need to give
double quotes
search for us single quotes is okay now
and now
area
hyphen level
equal to search
one second let me try to make it okay
search here and uh followed by a few
more properties
so the first property i'm trying to use
it a part of this
area search we say area
hyphen
okay described by and here we give the
value called basic iphone
hyphen add-on to
okay so this is how we are trying to add
it now
after this what next after this we would
like to use another div tag now
div and here we say class
equal to inside this class we may offer
a few more details
uh okay like i can see input group
input iphone
hyphen group iphone
append okay that is a div class
and inside this dip class i would like
to use also another button
here we say class
equal to btn space btn
hyphen
primary okay type equal to what it is a
button
so that's it and after that within this
button i would like to use
i class equal to
fs space fa hyphen
search
that's it so this is how we are making
it first and now we'll be going ahead
with the next level
okay so let's get started with the next
point now so we have finished our div
and dip form now let me try to organize
it properly
okay now the div div and this part is
getting close and now we would like to
talk about our navbar part
okay so here i'm starting with the nav
point
so here accelerometry
and here i give the name called bar
just to tell you like this would be the
navbar related
stuff here i'll start with my url tag
now
so inside my ul i say you will space
class equal to
number okay so we have a call
navbar hyphen nav
okay space ml hyphen
auto space ml
hyphen md iphone
0 so that is for my ul so within this
url i'll be having
some li class also so we have got li
within this li
i am saying class equal to
now what are the details i want i say
nav hyphen item
okay nav hyphen i item space
drop down
okay so now hyphen item space what a
drop down now
now within this li tag okay
i want to use lot of other tags too so
first tag i'm using this for anchor tag
okay
so in this anchor tag we want to say a
and followed by class equal to
well i'm saying nav hyphen
link followed by drop down
hyphen toggle
okay after this space id
equal to user
drop down
okay id equal to what user drop down
href
equal to we just make it as just a hash
because i'm not taking anywhere after
this hash we say roll
equal to button so roll will be
a button type and the job doesn't get
over here
we also have some option called data
hyphen toggle
okay data hyphen toggle equal to drop
down
equal to drop down space we
also want to use some area has popup
okay you can see there's a property
called idiot has pop-up
so i just said true use exactly it does
have
and we also want to say area hyphen
expanded you see now area hyphen
expanded
we're also saying false apart of that
we also want to use some image within
this
so image
so in this image we want to say src
src will be entered
okay
assets under the assets it will be under
id
dot png this is already sorry jvg
there's already one value available
inside this id
png alt we don't want it as of now
if you want you can add it otherwise i'm
just leaving it blank i'm just using
this option called style
equal to now
border hyphen
border hyphen radius
okay this hyphen border it is how much
you want to give i'm saying fifty
percent
that is a css style okay and followed by
width
how much weight you're giving it i'm
saying 50 pixels
50 pixels
okay that's the whole idea for this
now the anchor tag is getting closed
okay so here the anchor tag is closed
after the ignite tag is closed we would
like to give another tip class now for
the drop down
so we say this div class will have some
of the set of properties which is
available
i say div
class equal to
drop down
okay hyphen menu and
followed by
iphone menu hyphen
right okay
and followed by we want to use area
area hyphen you can see this option
called
label by okay equal to give the option
name called user
drop down i'm just giving the value user
drop down value has been given now
within this div tag itself we'll be
adding some new
more values what those values will be
i'm saying
anchor tag
class equal to now that is an anchor tag
class equal to drop down
drop down hyphen item okay space
href equal to hash
href equal to what hash
we are giving the value called what
settings
okay now i just copy this line
okay and uh let's have only two
for a time being so drop down hyphen
item hdf settings and we give
it a give
activity lock
that's the value for activity log
okay anchor tag is getting close now
here after that
we use another tab tag here it's called
nested tip tag
okay so in this div tag we want to use
class
equal to drop down hyphen item
drop down hyphen item and
i would say better drop an iphone
divider
drop down hyphen divide it
as a value and in the same div tag
this div tag is getting closed here and
we're using one more
okay and class
equal to drop down hyphen item
dropdown item item hrf equal to
give the value the one which you want to
give it i am saying hash
okay it's difficult to what
hash let me close this
yeah hdf equal to hash and
we just use router link equal to as you
know it very well
in typical navigation we always use the
router link rather than normal href
and here we're giving the name call what
login
okay and here we can use
router link active equal to
active okay and here we get the name
called
log out log
[Music]
out okay so that's the value which we're
giving it now
anchor tag is closed and here the div
tag is closed
li ul and nav so let me organize it
this one
this one this one
and lab tag let me format this
okay so that's what my file is okay so
let's continue to this
so we have created the value till now
and we want to start with this
div diagonal now with this div tag
we would like to have few more classes
added now
we say div id equal to
you can just give the name call layout
site info
layout sidenav
so this is the first value we are taking
it now with this layout side now
a part of this would like to use another
div tag now
and inside this div we would like to
offer the id
equal to
layout site nav
whatever name we have used it underscore
now
that is a second div type we have it now
now within this we want to use the nav
okay with this snap we want to say class
equal to sb hyphen sidenav
sidenav hyphen menu
that value we are passing it to this
okay that is for
sb hyphen sidenav view or
along with this rather than menu i can
have another option with me
to make it even more better sb hyphen
sidenav
space accordion
accordion okay so according we're going
to give you the kind of flipping type of
moment
one after another sp hyphen
site nav sb iphone sidenav hyphen
dock and space id
equal to
side neverword side
accordion so this value we are using it
now
with this nav so within this snap
we would like to bring another div class
now by
saying live and inside this div
we will say class equal to
uh i would say sp hyphen
side nav hyphen
menu okay now within this div tag we
want to use another dev diagram
so you might be thinking so many tips i
guess that is why we want
to make it more organized we said dev
class
equal to nav
okay now within this div tag we would
like to use another div
do class equal to
here you want to say sp hyphen
sp iphone site name
hyphen menu hyphen
heading
site name hyphen menu hyphen heading
okay and in this we just given the value
called
code this is the value of this
okay so this is what for the first dip
tag
now within this div tag when this step
tag is closed
we want to use the anchor tag now a
class equal to
nav hyphen link
okay nav hyphen link followed by
href equal to give the name called
index dot html
so this is your href one second
hdf equal to index.html
now now within this anchor tag we want
to use the div tag now
okay and in this div we would like to
say class
equal to
sp hyphen nav
hyphen link hyphen icon
so div class equal to sp hyphen
nav hyphen link hyphen icon this is a
class of my tip tag right now okay
now this particular class
inside this we want to use the
i class something i plus
equal to fs space
fa hyphen
tachometer
tachometer hyphen alt
okay and we are closing this i tag is
getting close the tip tag is getting
close
okay and within this i'm giving the
value call what
dashboard
okay so a class equal to
giving this call nav link
and hsf equal to index dot
html and here we have the div tag which
is
getting close now and here the anchor
tag is closed
and after the anchor tag is closed we
can use few more div tags inside this
okay let's see about which of the div
tags are now left with
here we start another div tag
now inside this div we say class equal
to
sb hyphen
site nav okay sb hyphen site name
iphone menu hyphen heading
hyphen heading and now we want to use
one tool name called interface
so here we have a called dev diagram
after this we would like to use
another anchor tag
okay and now with this anchor tag we
want to say class
[Music]
equal to now um as we know it very well
we have given this call menu heading so
we get nav link collapse so we say
now hyphen link
space
collapse okay so that is a
class which we're using it now with my
anchor tag
okay collapsed after that we are saying
href
equal to hash
okay href equal to what hash and data
hyphen
toggle equal to collapse
so that's the value we're giving it to
my data toggle now after that we are
giving some more values here
one where we are giving is called data
target
yeah data target equal to here we're
giving this id
by saying collapse layout
collapse that is a
daily target and we just want to say
area
hyphen expanded area hyphen expanded
equal to
false and one more property i want to
give it
is called area hyphen controls area
hyphen controls
okay equal to collapse layer
collapse layouts one second
let me try to add it here
and edit it here
collapse layouts okay so anchor tag is
there
so within my anchor tag where it is
getting closed i just want to give
one more dev tag inside this
yeah so here we have
okay got within this div tag we want to
give some
additional property to this div so we
know it very well what type of
details we're talking about so we said
if class
equal to sp hyphen nav link
usb hyphen nav link
okay hyphen icon there is another class
we're using it now
and sorry
sv hyphen nav hyphen link that's the
first property we have taken let me
close this
and
okay so sb hyphen nav hyphen link
and a part of this you can just use
hyphen icon
iphone
icon okay within this
i can use i class so here
i'm using i class equal to
so which class you want to use it i'm
saying fs
space fa iphone
angle okay hyphen dom
so this is your i class which we are
defining it right now
okay closing this the i tag is getting
closed
along with the tip tag now okay and
anchor tag is
getting closed
okay anchor tag is getting close here
so inside this we would like to give
with the dev tag is getting close we
want to give home
any value which you want to give so
we're giving what over here
and this is where it's getting close
right now
okay so after the dip tag is getting
closed we're using this and
so later on we can go back and try to
implement more ideas
okay so we have finished in one point of
areas now we would like to go back and
start working with the rollable now
so now here with my application we want
to use
another div tag now so within this div
tag we want to use some classes
we set the space
class equal to row
okay after this i use one more div tag
and in this div tag we want to use one
more property here called
class equal to call hyphen
excel hyphen six
so six columns layout we are trying to
add it now here we are trying to say
div and with this div we say
class equal to
now see the properties now do class
equal to we're using card
space mb hyphen 4.
card space mb hyphen four we're using
this property
now after that we would like to use
another div tag
with using div plus
equal to header
i would rather say card hyphen header i
will say card
hyphen header so this div class
and inside this we want to say i
i class equal to
some addition declaration i'm saying fs
space fa hyphen
chart hyphen
area space mr hyphen 1
so closing this so i tag is getting
closed
here we're going to give the value name
called weekly analysis
weekly
weekly analysis okay so with this div
tag it is getting closed
i want to bring another tip tag inside
this
now with this div tag
we want to write another class here that
is known as call
class equal to card hyphen body so we
want to give
class equal to card hyphen class equal
to
card hyphen body
okay and this
classical cardiacs and body we want to
bring another thing inside this that is
called img
equal to now here
from the assets we want to use
area chart
area chart dot png so that location we
want to use it now
followed by width equal to 100
okay and
[Music]
height equal to 280
okay and here the tip tag is getting
closed
okay so we're talking about this
dev tag and there's another tip tag is
getting close below this
the third div tag is also getting close
now okay
so we totally have three div tag is
getting close and we would like to use
another tab diagonal
we want to set them class equal to
once again call hyphen
xs excel
hyphen six
so six columns layout you're talking
about
and after that we say div class
div class equal to card
space mb iphone 4.
okay dev classical card space mb hyphen
4 and again we use another div
tag okay and inside this div
we say class equal to
header name class equal to what
header rather i would say card hyphen
header
card hyphen header now now within this
dev tag
we want to use another i class
yeah so within this card hyphen header
we want to use the another
chart so as we've already seen we have
used this uh
assets hyphen chart area.chat png
in a similar way we would like to use
the same technique now
for the monthly report also okay
so we have a call called sn6 card mp4
okay we're using what card header so
in this the way we have used weekly
analysis
i just copy this the same
okay and i pasted it here
okay and here what i try to offer
not weekly analysis i would rather offer
monthly reports
okay monthly report and after the div
title is close card body
and now we talk about call bar chart.png
bar chart.png width equal to
100 the div tag is getting closed
here so this is how we're trying to use
it now
so just like that we can keep on using
some
another properties too now here
we want to use one more table
okay in this div tag we feel
class equal to
now let's provide another property here
so we said deb class equal to card
okay space mb iphone
4 and other details too
we were on this position called card
hyphen mv
[Music]
header so that is another div class we
are using it now
so inside this dev class we want to use
another i
i class
equal to here i am using once again fas
space fa hyphen
table space mr
hyphen one okay that's the position we
are using it right now
okay and after this i tag
here we define this option name called
employee data
employee data so here the div tag is
getting closed
okay so now what three properties we
have taken it now weekly monthly report
employee data now we would like to
create a table now
so whatever you are looking forward for
let's start we are saying
div class equal to
card hyphen body
okay now within this div class equal to
called hyphen body we're using another
tab tag here now
okay and inside this div tag will say
class equal to table hyphen
responsive so we want to use table
hyphen responsive
fine now after this we want to create a
table
okay within this table okay we would
like to create
table headed multiple things but let me
add some classes here
i'm saying table class equal to we want
to use table
space table hyphen border
border and after that we use id equal to
just give the name called data table
after this data table we say width
equal to 100
100 and also we want to use cell spacing
cell spacing
so some spacing we are giving equal to
zero that is for my table
and inside this table i can have table
head
okay under the table head i will be
using tr
so tr under which should be having ph
which is called table heading so we're
giving the first property
yeah so here i give name like this
i just copy this and take few more
property
name position
here we give call office
then age
then we keep started
and one more and that is on
salary so these are part of table
heading
tr is closed the head is closed now we
would like to use
t body we would like to use
keyboard you know inside the t body we
want to use tr
which is your table row under this we
want to use what
td that is called a table data so here
we can give the name
so the first value we are giving is
called tiger
nexon let me copy and paste it
so that is the first value second is
nonstop position so we are saying
system architect
okay system architect that is what my
table data
next we're looking forward for office we
give the office name called edinburgh
next it is asking for your age
let's give the age call 61
next is asking for the start date so we
just give
slash 0 4 25
and we can give it last which is asking
for the salary
and just say dollar
any random value i've given it now
okay so this is the first stable row is
basically closed
like that we can have multiple records
with me
i copy this and have another
and have another so as my number of
records you want you can basically have
it now
okay let me quickly change the name
this value called accountant
next value which we have it is called
tokyo
age 63
okay same and here we can give
okay and here you can change the values
later on if you want but for the display
purpose it's okay
okay so here the multiple things are
getting closed
your tea body is getting close your
table is getting closed
your tip tag is getting close your div
tank is getting closed and
after this we have got one more that is
the other okay after closing the last
dip tag we would like to also close
the main okay after this main uh we
would like to start working with this
photo part now
in this footer we would like to add some
new classes here i'm
saying class equal to py
iphone 4 space bg
hyphen light space
empty hyphen
auto okay followed by
we can use the another div tag and
inside this div
we can use class
equal to
container hyphen fluid
container hyphen fluid now there's
another div tag
okay inside this div we want to use what
class equal to d hyphen
flex okay space
align hyphen items
hyphen center space
justify
hyphen content
hyphen between
space small
okay now inside this div we would like
to use another div
reset the class
equal to text mounted text
hyphen muted
okay and we would like to offer
here let's go copyright
copyright
okay and
copy okay
space give the name
dot simply here or else
like this okay so div tag is getting
closed here now
after that you can use
tether f equal to you can just give hash
okay and now you can give the value call
what privacy policy
privacy policy okay and here in privacy
calls you can just give
ampersand
okay and
okay and after this again href
so after this we can use
but first anchor tag is getting closed
here after this privacy policy
okay so now another href
here hash rather than privacy policy i'm
gonna give
terms
okay in terms
give space
okay conditions
okay terms and conditions you don't need
this numb
and that's it so david photo is also
getting closed
dev tag is also getting closed so
photographs also and there's another div
tag is getting closed
and after that another day will be
included
okay and that's it body will be closed
post that
okay so there are a lot of space let me
try to remove
that's it so now let me format it
let's see what this is always confusion
so guys our
navbar component is ready and after that
we go back and try to add few more
things into my code
now we will create few more components
into my code so first component a part
of this
what we have seen i'm going to create
one more component name called toggle so
ng
space g space c space
toggle
okay a part of that we want to create
few more components here there is one
route so ng space g space c
space routes
okay so this component is ready along
with this
as we know it very well like there are
certain components which we have created
we also would like to create few more
components into my application
okay by saying ng
space g space c space uh
[Music]
let's see
so under the routes we have got what
charts is another component which we
have seen now
okay now in a similar way i would like
to create one more component under the
routes
and that is for login
component is ready along with this login
we would like to create a register
and along with this we would like to
also go back
and create one more component here that
is called
password
so charts login register password
so four components are ready now and
they're all inside what
they're all inside under the roots okay
so these all components are now ready
with me and we'll be basically making
all those components as associated
inside my routes part
clear now so which component used what
that we have to basically consider it
now
so since they're all of the components
now so under my
app.routing.model.tx we have to
basically provide a routings here now
so here we know conspire routes equal to
blank so let me try to say
path okay path colon
if nothing has been given so the by
default component will be what
component will be
navbar component
so this network components automatically
comes up here
after that if path is of what
is static
component is what
toggle component okay and here we are
saying
path match colon
full okay along with this
we're giving one more path
colon login
so here component
colon login component
i'm going to put comma
component c small okay now like this
next we talk about call path
colon register
okay and here component colon
register component
now let's talk about what path colon
what change password
so here we say
component comma
component colon which command we are
trying to say
password component
also next
we want to say path
colon
charts then
so these are the components are now
available to me
so these components are now all set and
later on we'll be combining all the
files together
in my system one by one okay everybody
so our all
components are now all ready so you see
like we have got navbar
which contains all the necessary tags
whichever is required for my application
here we have a basically the login and
this login.component.html
actually contains all the relative part
which is
related to your login like you can talk
about call
email you talk about your password you
have a call remember me
and forgot password these type of
details are available inside your
logincomponent.html now so this is
basically the code
okay which contains your login related
stuffs now
so it contains only few properties like
you talk about like email address
it contains what a password and only the
buttons
through which user can login through
followed by when i see my
password so this password
file that is called
password.component.html
it contains the details regarding to
your password so that
the user can give the password details
or in case
the user has or want to change the
password so we can give the details like
okay you can enter your email id
address where i can send the password to
you so here we have
this email address we haven't
implemented
your i would say any kind of
sending the email to your uh
registered email id that logic hasn't
been implemented but it's just for the
demo
like how exactly you can bring this
password
forgot condition inside your system now
so this is what
the password and here we have a link for
the login and here we have a
registration
followed by if you think about call
register register contains that
register.component.html and here if you
see there are a few details which are
expecting from the user like in first
name last name
email password confirm password so these
are the quick fields which i'm expecting
from the user to enter
and here it's a button for
you know confirming a password and this
is what exactly the
links which are available for the login
okay and for the login.html file so this
is a simple
registration form which is available to
me and that is last which is available
for me
for that for me that is called toggling
part in toggle part we are just
offering the details with regards to
your how
in case if you want to toggle you can
change the settings
okay based on between the settings and
activity
okay so these are the links which are
available through which
you can change all different type of
toggling part whether you would like to
enable
or not enable this is something which is
related to your page in case if you
click on that link
so 401 page 404 page 500 page which will
be available to us
now let's try to run the code and check
how the final application really looks
like in
okay so now i'm trying to run my
application
by
saying npm space start
once again
okay
okay and now i'm trying to say
in game space start let the project
start now
and we'll see how it really looks like
it
so it is compiling all the files
okay and finally let's try to execute
localhost 4200
let me see what is an issue right now
okay let me check meanwhile try to run
it run it again
okay now i finally uh i'm into my
current project right now so
it was the wrong location where the
project was available so
i just like to say npm space start and
let the project run
so project is picking up till the time i
say localhost 400.
and beautiful guys this is how exactly
projects really looks like it
isn't isn't amazing right now see how
beautiful your project really looks like
it
this is what exactly the dashboard you
have it and this is the nav bar which is
available to you
getting it now see how better and
beautiful it looks and organize
so this is like in real time dashboard
which is available you can see the
birthdays you have it
you talk about you know company
announcement
quick links these are all basically
available these are the charts which you
can see
can give some dummy values and these are
the charts will be really available to
you
so this is how the employee records
which we had it which we are displaying
it right now
and this is how exactly the chat looks
like it
so weekly analysis and monthly analysis
this is the dashboard and here the links
are there but they're all dummy links we
haven't made it but you can certainly
make it further
okay you can search for
anything but it is not working right now
because it is just for the display
because nothing more than that
it is a home which you can see written
like in profile
this is like the profile which we have
created by default the name is called
kate adams
uh and this is designation like an
account it
and uh like you can talk about like
home under the home you have a profile
we have called settings
so nothing is the research in the
settings so it is just a static record
attendance it will be bringing you back
to the same page we have a call
confirmation
travel expenses these are basically the
dummy links which are available we
haven't made it
which you can see new development okay
part of that you see like profile we
have it settings
account activity if you see we have
called login and register
this three page if you remember we have
created it under this
system so you can see we have a got
login
we have a call register we have a call
password
so these are you are able to see this
now when you say change password
you see like how they have given to you
they're not actually working
but they're just like in dummy option
and you can see it will be taking you
directly to the sign up option
okay now here in your
settings once again you can look forward
for the login
it works like in a typical model how it
comes
apart of that we also have this
call register so these are the fields of
registration form
and
you see about activity activity we have
because these pages are available there
are basically dummy pages which
we have created download confirmation so
really it
this project really gives you the kind
of sense of in real time
how your application angular application
can really
make your ui more attractive which are
more competitive in market
so i hope you guys love this project so
we have developed most of the codes
by our own except few which we have
taken it from
online that is nothing but call uh
especially those
images as well as uh what to say some
javascript
related libraries if you see which we
are using it right now here
you think about think about this uh
your navbar.com.html if you see like
these are the libraries we have taken it
from internet
because certainly we don't type it
because it is taking long time to type
certainly we have taken from internet
and some images also we have taken it
from the internet
which are there under the assets folder
too so if you see
under the assets we have a lot of images
like an area chart
bar chart chart so this we have
downloaded from the internet
so hope you guys love this project thank
you very much and happy learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified click here